Jazz, kommt das Podcast aufo, mit Tizum, Will, Florentino, Stefan, vielen Dank, das Ballad. Ja, das Ballad richtig, Stefan hat es eingeschickt, vielen, vielen Dank an diesen kleinen Chartstürmer, den ihr wahrscheinlich noch häufiger hören werdet und den auch wir hier jeden Tag für den Rest unseres Lebens. Die sind niemals still. Ja, stimmt, wir sind niemals still. Wir halten nicht unsere Klappe. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Wir kriegen es nicht hin. Es geht immer weiter. Ey, du hörst ja auch sehr gerne beim Reden zu, ne? Ja, ja.
Anscheinend hören wir uns ja beide sehr gerne beim Reden zu.
Wie arrogant muss man eigentlich sein. Dass man sagt, man nimmt seine Stimme auf und schickt das in den Äther. Jede Woche. Es ist so, wir hören uns alle zu, was wir zu erzählen haben. Warum glaubst du, du bist so viel besser als alle anderen? ja herzlich willkommen zu neuen ausgaben von Das Podcast-Ufo mit Tizzi und Willi, wie immer. Ja, Tizzi und Willi, da sind wir bei. Also auch im neuen Jahr geht es gewohnt weiter, aber wir sind heute in Hamburg unterwegs. Si, und deswegen klingt es ein bisschen anders, ja, besser, und es fühlt sich auch ein bisschen anders. Und es sieht auch ein bisschen anders aus.
Die Stadt der Träume.
Die uns bei Patreon folgen, werden uns sehen.
Sorry dafür an der Stelle, dass ihr uns auch dabei sehen müsst.
Ja.
Aber ihr seht, der Raum ist a little bit different, wie der Engländer sagt.
Er trägt ein schlichtes schwarzes Shirt.
Und Florentin einen schlichten schwarzen Hoodie.
Also viel gibt's da nicht zu sehen, um ganz ehrlich zu sein.
Aber der Gesichtsausdruck von Stefan verspricht Gutes, er ist voller Hoffnung, voller Vertrauen.
Aber es gibt mal jetzt schon mal aus Spaß nach vorne und ihr seht, wie mir jegliches Leben aus dem Gesicht gewichen sein wird.
Die Zeit reisst alle Wunden wieder auf. Muss man ja auch mal sagen. Sie heilt alle Wunden, aber reisst die Zeit eher alle Wunden wieder auf? Heilung aufreissen, Heilung aufreissen. Das macht die Zeit, weil irgendwann... Die ist so ein Pflaster so. Die ist so ein Pflaster und kommt immer wieder und dann kommt es immer wieder an und man denkt, ach die Wunde hatte ich doch eigentlich schon besiegelt, aber nein, sie wird nochmal aufgerissen. Verletzt du dich selber? Ab und zu, ja, ich kratze mich selber ab und zu. Obwohl es nicht juckt? Obwohl es nicht juckt, ich habe immer so raue Hände, was du ganz ehrlich sagen, jetzt mal so ein bisschen kälter ist. Klar, kein Problem. So raue Hände. Ist normal. Und ich benutze jetzt auch mittlerweile Zahnseide, bin ich jetzt sehr, sehr stolz. Letztes Jahr bin ich in die Zahnseide Business eingestiegen.
In die Zahnseide Industrie.
Bin ich eingestiegen und ich will dir meine ganz allgemeine Frage stellen.
Du hast zwei Reinigungsprozesse.
Einer, der ist etwas gröber und einer ist etwas feiner.
Okay, ich versuche es so abstrakt wie möglich zu halten.
Wir haben einen groben Reinigungsprozess und einen feinen Reinigungsprozess. Welchen zuerst? Grob. Natürlich. Erst grob, dann fein? Natürlich. Okay, ich sage nämlich andersrum. Ich sage erst fein, dann grob. Erst Zahnseide, dann Zähneputzen. Nein, beim Zähneputzen verschiebst du ja Dinge auch in Zwischenräume oder sowas. Du sagst erst Zähneputzen, dann Zahnseide. Um deins umzudrehen, ist ja, wir übertragen es mal auf die Bearbeitung eines Marmorblocks. Du benutzt das kleine Miniskalpell vor dem Hammer. Ja, aber das darfst du nicht machen, weil jetzt hast du einen Reinigungsprozess mit einem kreativen Prozess. Schaffungsprozess. Verglichen, das ist nicht das gleiche. Ist es nicht das Bearbeiten eines Marmor-Prozesses, eines Marmor-Blocks, das Bereinigen des unnützen Spaces? Nein, angenommen, du musst eine Terrasse sauber machen.
Und du hast einen Hochdruckstrahler und einen Mob.
So, dann würde ich erst... Du hast einen Hochdruckstrahler.
Genau, erst fein, dann grob.
Nee, Hochdruck ist nicht fucking fein.
Das ist nämlich dein Problem, du überträgst es falsch.
Du überträgst es falsch in deinem Köpfchen.
Okay, dann sagen wir mal, du hast eine Zahnbürste für die Räden.
Du hast eine Zahnbürste für die Räden.
Anderes weiteres Beispiel.
Perfektes Beispiel.
Rasenmäher und Kantenschneider, Heckenschneider, so einen kleinen. Okay. Das ist das gleiche, also sozusagen der, das ist wie immer im Blog, aber okay, bist du plötzlich on board, also I take it, I take this win already. Nein, nein, nein. Also du hast eine grosse Rasenfläche, die ist zu gross, die ist zu hochgewachsen, du hast einen Rasenmäher, der ist der grobe, offensichtlich die Zahnbürste und du hast den kleinen filigranen Detailschneider. Natürlich gehst du erst über den ganzen... Erst fein die Ecken und dann alles nochmal grob wegnehmen. Aber im Idealfall kriegst du ja schon viel von den Ecken weg, wenn du mit dem Rasenmäher einmal drüber gehst. Das ist ja viel mehr Aufwand. Du musst ja richtig viel Arbeit machen, um diese kleinen Dreckscheisse noch wegzubekommen. Also machst du natürlich erstmal mal den Rasenmäher alles platt und dann guckst du, was ist stehen geblieben, wo kam ich jetzt nicht dran. Anderes Beispiel, Saugen und Kerblech. Uff, Saugen und Kerblech, ja, ja, hm, ich, ich bück mich doch nicht. Ich finde, Saugen und Kerblech ist dasselbe, nur unterschiedliche Grössen. Es ist nicht feiner und spezieller. Ja, ja. Ich meine nur, wenn ich erst Zahnseide benutzen würde und dann nehme ich meinen dicken, klobigen, riesen Zahnbesen, ja, habe ich doch Angst, dass der Dreck verschiebt, irgendwie Plack von aussen nach innen, weil der ist ja ein bisschen grobmotorisch. Der verschiebt ja vielleicht dann Dinge wieder in den Zahnzwischenraum.
Aber ich würde mir immer denken, dass wenn du erst die Zähne putzt und dann Zahnseide machst, dann wurde der Zwischenbereich der Zähne nicht richtig geputzt, weil da war ja noch der Schnodder drin. Der ist ja dann sozusagen dem Putzen entgangen. Und dann legst du das ja frei, aber es wird dann nicht mehr geputzt. Es wurde dann nur durch die Zahnseide sozusagen freigelegt. Aber das da drin wurde ja selber nicht mehr geputzt. Aber du putzt ja mit der Zahnseide ja auch. Aber nicht wirklich, da ist keine ... Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist ein gutes Argument. Das ist ein gutes Argument, du wackelst überzeugend mit dem Kopf, muss ich gerade sagen. Aber es ist ja, da ist ja keine Zahnpasta mit drin. Du hast ja bei der Zahnpasta auch, das ist ja so Chemikalien da irgendwas drin, so.
Ich glaube, du bist auf dem Holzweg. Ich sage erst fein, erst fein, dann grob. Ich sage erst grob, dann fein, dann Mundspülung. Okay, jetzt kommt aber noch eine komplett wilde, chaotische Komponente mit rein, die für mich so nicht mehr funktioniert. Doch, also ich, oder was ich auch gut finde, ist, damit du auf Nummer sicher bist, grob, fein, kurz grob, Zahnspülung. Okay, aber sagen wir mal zum Beispiel, du machst die Badewanne sauber oder die Dusche, dann nehme ich die Zahnbürste und mache erst einmal die Kanten und Fugen fein und dann brauche ich alles nochmal mit Wasser ab. Dann brauche ich alles mit Wasser ab. Aber es gibt keinen Grund dafür. Also okay, fair enough, du machst es so. Aber wenn du die Fugen am Ende machst, dann musst du ja das nochmal wegspülen. Weil du leerst ja die Fugen dann nur, aber das Schnodder ist ja noch da. Und das muss ja dann nochmal alles weggespült werden. Und dafür nehme ich den groben Reinigungsprozess. Deswegen sage ich erst fein, weil das Grobe nimmt dann alles mit, auch das, was du aus den feinen Fugen rausgekratzt hast. Wohingegen andersrum wäre das ja noch so, du hast ja keinen Abtransport, du hast keinen wirklichen Abtransport dafür. Das nehme ich schon als Gegenbeispiel jetzt zumindest mal auf. Aber ich sehe es, da das vielleicht auch nicht so gut vergleichbar, ich finde es auf jeden Fall, da verstehe ich das. Andere Frage, benutzt du zuerst Haarshampoo oder erst Duschgel? Stefan, komm. Als ob ich das ich habe eine Soße für alles. Ah, okay. Ich habe da die Süssauersoße in der Dusche stehen, die kommt überall ran. Da mache ich keine Unterscheidung. Trotzdem wäscht du, machst du dann die Dusche aus, seifst dich einmal komplett ein und dann dusche wieder an. Nee, nee, nee. Ich habe ja einen Duschkopf in der Hand. Ich bin ja ein händischer Duscher. Ja. Ich habe Duschkopf immer in der Hand. Ich auch. Und zum einen Schamponieren tue ich den in die Halterung oben, schamponiere mich ein und dann wird wieder gebraust. Ja, aber machst du erst Haare oder erst Körper? Haare dann Körper, von oben nach unten. Also ich mache nur Haare und das nimmt es dann mit auf dem Weg nach unten. Das denke ich mir auch. Da sind wir ähnlich, das sind wir genau gleich. Das ist ja die Waschlawine, sozusagen, dass man von oben nach unten wäscht. Ansonsten wäre überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das würde überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Weil wenn ich am Ende die Haare rausmache, da kommt die ganze Schlotter runter, ist der ganze Körper wieder dreckig. Ja. Ja, sehe ich ganz genau so. Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare grob und dann fein oder erst fein und dann grob. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass ich recht habe. Tipp, wenn ihr euch verrennt in solchen Streits und ihr merkt, oh, hier gibt es gerade kein Vor und Zurück und wenn das so weitergeht, kann ich mit der Person nicht mehr einen Podcast machen, zum Beispiel. Dann versucht er nachher etwas zu finden, wo ihr beide gleich seid, wie gerade beim Duschbeispiel. Ah, das war ein Verbrüderungsversuch. War ein Verbrüderungsversuch, dann hast du dir alles eingerissen, weil du wieder mit dem alten Thema angefangen hast. Weil ich gesagt habe, ich habe Recht, ich habe Recht, ich habe Recht. Ich habe Recht, ich habe Recht, du bist ein Arschloch, du bist ein Arschloch. Okay, du würdest sagen, das war falsch, das war nicht gut in der Diskussion? Das hat der Diskussion nicht geholfen, würdest du sagen? Das hat definitiv nicht geholfen und ich würde sagen, es ist kindisch und albern. Als ich mit dem Fuss auf dem Boden gestampft habe und gesagt habe, ich habe aber recht, recht, recht. Genau. Okay, da würdest du jetzt konstruktiv sagen, das war nicht gut? Ich würde konstruktiv sagen, es war kindisch und albern. Okay, und als ich mich auf den Boden geworfen habe, mit den Fäusten auf den Boden getrommelt habe und gesagt, fein, fein, fein, fein, fein, dann grob, das war nicht rhetorisch nicht ideal gelöst. Ich meine, du hast am Ende gewonnen auf deine Art, weil ich mich zurückgezogen habe aus dem Streit und dem Zimmer. Ja. Von daher muss man, das muss man dir schon zugute halten. Auf der anderen Seite würde ich sagen, es ist eher keine gute Streitkultur. Sketch-Idee, Rhetorikkurs für Kleinkinder. Super. Wo so ein Kleinkind, wirklich auch mit so einem Schal und so einem Sacko und ein Rhetorikkurs und so. Wichtig ist immer, an der Kasse, je mehr Lärm, desto mehr Süssigkeiten. Ist der vorne, steht auch ein Kind? Auch ein Kleinkind, ja. Und alle schreiben so mit. Und schreiben so mit. So, Judith, willst du mal kurz rauskommen? Ja, klar. Willst du mal kurz rauskommen? Okay, wir üben das jetzt einfach mal an der Kasse, du willst die Smarties. Okay. Du nimmst die Smarties, zeigst auf die Smarties, wie würdest du es eingehen? Mutter, ich würde dich höflich bitten, noch eine Packung Smarties mitzunehmen, weil ich kann es gebrauchen, es gibt mir diesen gewissen Energieschub und ich habe schon lange nicht mehr gequengelt und deswegen fände ich es schön, wenn im Austausch von mein gutes Benehmen ich vielleicht diese Erfahrung Smarties bekäme. Okay, klasse, welchen Fehler hat Judith gerade gemacht? Ja, Rebecca? Alles falsch, hat nicht geschrieben, nicht geweint und wenn die Smarties will, muss sie die nehmen, aufs Kassenband legen und wenn die Mama das wieder wegnimmt, ganz doll anfangen zu schreien. Ja, danke, das war ein ganz klassischer Anfängerfehler, du hast Argumente geliefert. Judith, das ist ein ganz klassischer Anfängerfehler, du hast Argumente geliefert, du hast versucht, überzeugende Begründungen zu geben. Aber ich habe versucht, wie der wachsende Mensch... Nein, wir machen jetzt mal die Übung. Eins, zwei, drei, Schreien, Boden, Fäuste auf dem Boden, Herr Mann.
Schreien, auf den Boden legen, Fäuste auf den Boden, okay? Also das, ich nenne es immer die SBF-Methode, ja, Schreien, Boden, Fäuste. SBF kann man sich ganz einfach merken, SBF, okay? Also, das ist eine ganz einfache Eselsbrücke, denkt einfach immer an SBF.
Okay, ganz einfache Eselsbrücke.
Ich habe die Eselsbrücke noch nicht mitbekommen.
Also, du möchtest
jetzt die
Smarties, wir schauen uns das noch mal an, Judith, bitte.
Mama Smarties!
Smarties, Smarties, Smarties, Smarties, Smarties, Smarties! B, B, denk an B. Boden. Mh, Mh, Njee! Sehr gut, wunderbar, sehr schön. Haben wir doch wunderbar, das war's für heute. Und dann kommen beim Rausgehen noch manche Kleinkinder an den Tisch und dann meinten so, ja, ist bemerkbar, ich hatte ja auch am Wochenende so diese Gespräche. Dann kommen sie zu dir und dann so, vielen Dank nochmal für den Tag. Und ich schicke den so einen Apfel auf den Tisch. Ach klar, vielen, vielen Dank, ja, danke, danke schön. Sie machen die besten Kurse. Ich will auch meine Schokolade! Was ist denn deine Note für den Kurs? Das sind zwei, also bin auf die ein. Okay, eins. Das ist die ein. Sehr gut. Wunderbar, du hast viel gelernt. Wow. Vielen Dank. Gerne. Wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr. Für die Fortgeschrittenen. Ja, cool. Rhetorik-Kurs für Kinder. Dieser Sketch wurde Ihnen präsentiert von dem Bundesministerium für frühkindliche Bildung. Bildungsministerium. Bildet euch! Bildet euch! Bildet euch, bitte! Deutschland wird da sehr schlecht abgeschnitten beim Pisa-Test. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Aber gibt's auch so ein, weil natürlich ist es wichtig, Schule, dass man lernt, lesen, schreiben, rechnen, klar. Falt zu auf, wenn auf den Tisch zu hauen. Ich hau nicht auf den Tisch, ich mache ja meine Hände unterm Tisch. Du traust von unten gegen den Tisch. Und er gibt es aber dem, aber was ich gut finde, ist, wenn es auch so eine Art Kreativitätstest gäbe. Also wenn man einerseits sagt, wir testen sozusagen die Hard Facts, die Hard Skills bei Pisa, aber eben auch, wie gut können die malen, wie gut können die Texte schreiben, sich ausdrücken, haben die Fantasie. Das fände ich auch cool. Meine grosse Kritik an der Pisa-Studie ist nämlich auch, sie ist schief, sie ist schief, denn sie hinkt und alles ist schief und es ist kurz vorm Umkippen. Weil das Problem ist nämlich, die testen halt so, 15-Jährige werden gemessen.
Ah, schwer ist das. und es ist kurz vor umkippen weil das problem ist nämlich die testen also 15 jährige werden gemessen die müssen dann rechnen und sowas und genau wie will man weil ich finde es ja nervig als 15 jähriger weisst du was ich denke steckt die in den raum stellt den alle musik Instrumente hin, Requisiten, Kostüme, Skripte von irgendwelchen coolen Theaterstücken und dann lasst sie machen, was sie wollen, gibt ihnen Fingerfarbe und Leinwände. so fuck it dann können die halt noch nicht so gut rechnen und schreiben die können aber sie sollen miteinander umgehen stellt die coole pädagogen pädagoginnen dahin die irgendwie gut
mit denen umgehen und die aufs Soziale vorbereiten und sowas. Dann lassen sie sich künstlerisch selbst verwirklichen, gucken, was sie machen und dann rechnen und lesen und blablabla. Das kommt dann irgendwann später. Kann man auch machen. Ich finde, Pisa kann man machen, aber wir brauchen auch Kisa. Wir brauchen auch den künstlerischen Kreativtest. Ja, so dass wir auch Kieser mal testen, so wie gut sind die Bilder, es stimmt die Perspektive. Kinder, künstlerisch kindlicher Kreativtest, KKK, super Name, Eingänge, so noch kurz mal nachdenken, aber und dann genau, also der KKK tritt in Kraft, wir messen, wie gut können die singen, wir machen so ein The Voice-artiges Ding. Genau. Wie gut wird gezeichnet und gemalt?
Ja.
Wie gut wird musiziert?
Theater.
Und Theater gespielt?
Genau, Literaturkritiker, Dramaturgen, Theaterkritiker müssen das neutral bewerten.
Und dann ist die Schlagzeile, Deutschland stinkt in Pisa ab, aber auf Kisa auf Platz zwei.
Bei KKK auch mal wieder auf Platz zwei.
Es bräuchte natürlich jetzt irgendeine Gemeinschaft, die international das Ganze überwachen könnte. Vielleicht so eine Art Clan oder sowas. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr sozusagen sich darum kümmern. Okay, und dieser Clan, der KKK-Clan, würde sich dann halt ausserbehördlich darum kümmern, dass es mit Deutschland nach vorne geht. Genau, also die würden dann sozusagen auch das Ruder übernehmen und dann einfach mal die richtigen Impulse setzen, damit es weitergeht. Also das können wir so unterschreiben. Für uns und ich sind dafür, dass der KKK Deutschland übernimmt und wieder nach vorne bringt. Also ohne Zweifel ist das genau, was wir gerade denken. Also halt eine frühkindliche … Das … Sie hörten einen satirischen Beitrag zum Thema Pleonasmen, denn tatsächlich steht das K ja schon für Klan, das muss man also nicht noch mal erwähnen, wie zum Beispiel auch bei HIV-Virus steht das V bereits für Virus. Man muss das nicht noch mal … Und sie Trottel sagen die ganze Zeit HIV-Virus, also, ich weiß nicht wofür hi steht, Hyper ... High Intensity? High Intensity Virus Virus. So, nach dem Motto reden sie die ganze Zeit, sie trotteln. Sie absoluter Vollidiot. Oder KKK-Klan, Wild Kuklux-Klan-Klan. Bullshit. Hören Sie sich überhaupt mal selber beim Red Bullshit, Bullshit, Sie labern Bullshit.
Pleonasmen, habe ich letztens gelernt, Akronym, A-D-A-C, A-Pronym, wenn die wiederum ein Wort ergeben, wie Elster, elektronische Steuer. Oder Peter. Bei Peter bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das zählt. Dann hast du dich aber nicht so gut eingehlt. Weil es ist ja nicht so, es ist ja kein, also es klingt wie ein echtes Wort, aber es ist kein echtes Wort. Elster nicht mit A am Ende? Nee, Elster, elektronisches Roro. Rein damit in die Steuer, du Fiskus, du kleiner Fiskus. Elster, elektronische Steuer, sowas. Einfach nur, ich will es mal gesagt haben, damit ihr wisst, dass ich schlau bin, Akronym, Apronym, nur um das mal gesagt zu haben. Politische Folge heute, oder? Politische Folge ist eine politische Folge heute, wie es gewählt wird. Du machst diesen Kniff, den habe ich mal gehört, machen Politiker häufig, du nickst, wenn du was sagst. Ja. Und das führt dazu, dass man das Gegenüber einlullt ein bisschen und derjenige, diejenige auch anfängt, das zu spiegeln. Ja. Und ich in meinem Fall nehme das dann auf. Ja. Da bedenke ich die ganze Zeit, was für ein fucking Unsinn, da wirst wirst du eigentlich aber durch dein einlullendes langsames schwabbelnicken sage ich ja okay klar oder wahrscheinlich recht ja ist natürlich auch für hip hop oder auch für metal natürlich wichtig einfach das einhämmernde ja ja ja das ist gute musik und die haben uns tatsächlich dadurch glauben machen dass es tatsächlich gute musik ist gute musikrichtung ist aber isturchtbar. Es ist absolut furchtbar und ich bin eher ein Fan von... Sanften Klängen, Klassik. Sanften Klängen. Wollen wir noch deinen peinlichen Spotify-Jahresrückblick besprechen? Nee, können wir nicht. Bei mir auch nicht. Können wir tatsächlich nicht besprechen. Also absolut nicht. Es passt nicht. Richtig peinlich. Ja, bei mir auch peinlich. Richtig peinlich, ich schäme mich wirklich dafür und Spotify sagt mir ins Gesicht, du hast keinen Musikgeschmack. Ja. Du hast einfach keinen Musikgeschmack. Das ist so unangenehm bei mir. Also auch die meistgehörten Songs würde ich auch so nicht unterschreiben. Ich mag auch vier davon nicht. Ich finde, man sollte da auch rechtliche Schritte ermöglichen, dass man dagegen einen Spruch erhebt und sagen kann, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Und dann so, ja, aber Stefan, du hast jeden Mittwoch von eins bis drei Uhr nachts nur Dua Lipa gehört. Ja. Bei mir sind auch, also ich verstehe auch manche Songs nicht und auch den Topkünstler nicht. Wer ist es? Nee, kann ich nicht sagen. Komm, wer ist es? Nee, kann ich nicht sagen, möchte ich auch nicht sagen. Musst du jetzt sagen. Da komme ich mit einem pretentious Arschloch rüber und ich kenne jetzt schon deinen fucking Ah, es ist Richard Wagner. Aber das Ding ist ja, wenn du halt Ach Gott, komm, jetzt muss er raushauen. Ja, aber wenn du halt, ich denke mir, wenn du eine Oper hörst, dann ist es ja schon dein Topkünstler. Weißt du, es ist ja sehr viel Zeit. Ich würde überhaupt nicht, ich habe nicht so viele Tracks von dem Bangers gehört, aber wenn man halt mal, keine Ahnung, Zugfahrt das hört, ist es ja schon der Lieblingskünstler. Ich bin auch nicht viel besser, ich habe wahrscheinlich den langweiligsten Top-Künstler, den man haben kann, wo man wirklich so sagt, okay, du bist der Standard-Mensch, sozusagen. Taylor Swift. Top-Künstler Mozart. Wirklich? Auch lame. Mozart? Das ist richtig lame, ja. Wir haben beide Klassiken. Einfach, aber es ist natürlich über langen Zeitraum verteilt halt hier und da und manchmal schläft man ja auch ein und dann läuft das die ganze Nacht und dann warst das so durch. Ich glaube glaube beim Klassik ist es halt so, es sind lang, es sind halt, wie viel Prozent, Top-Prozent, bist du bei Mozart?
Das weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung, das ist eine gute Fanbase.
Ich denke mir halt, auch bei Klassik ist es halt easy, Top-Künstler zu werden, weil die halt krassere Laufzeiten haben.
Du hörst dich halt länger. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Wohingegen, wenn ich eine normale Pop-Playlist anmache, dann höre ich drei Minuten jeden zu.
Je länger der Track, desto mehr hört man insgesamt davon? Die Musikrichtung, die die längsten Tracks hat, da hört man mehr davon, als die, die kurze Tracks haben? Wenn du eine Playlist hast, alle Popsongs sind drei Minuten lang, und dann wäre ein Song neun Minuten lang, ist das natürlich, wenn du die Playlist einmal durchhörst, das ist dein Popkünstler. Stark. Aber nicht mal drei halt schon stark okay ja dann haben wir schon mehr davon haben wir schon geklärt ja ich glaube das ist ich glaube das ist es und natürlich klassik auch noch hörst du häufig im hintergrund obwohl deswegen glaube ich man wundert sich an wenn man es so sieht schwarz auf weiss dass man da mehr gehört. Aber ich glaube, weil es keine aktive Musikbeschäftigung ist, sondern es läuft im Hintergrund beim Schreiben oder beim Bahnfahren oder Schlafen oder sowas. Oder man macht es einfach an, damit man am Ende des Jahres irgendwie gebildet wirkt, dass man sagt, okay, einfach nochmal die Nacht durch. Genau, denn das war ja mein grösster Wunsch, jetzt gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt Richard Wagner rauszuhauen aus meinem Topkünstler. Wahnsinnig sympathisch und cool und unverfänglich und what the fuck, einfach wahnsinnig unsympathisch. Aber meine anderen Popkünstler sind alles PopkünstlerInnen und das ist schon auch fucking weird, weil ich weiß nicht, ich bin ja auch, die Lieblingsmusikrichtung ist Rock. Also Richard Wagner ist auf Platz eins, danach gefolgt von so Lizzo-esken Pop-KünstlerInnen und dann steht er bei Lieblingsmusikrichtung ist Rock, also all over the place und dann kriegt man ja auch diesen Begriff jetzt neu zu, also man ist ja passt in eine von verschiedenen Personengruppen, da bin ich Gestaltenwandler, was ja passt. Mhm. Und dann sehr spannend auch die Stadt, die man bekommen hat. Jeder hat ja eine Stadt bekommen dieses Mal. Da gab es ja das grosse Münster-Mysterium, weil sehr viele Menschen in Deutschland Münster bekommen haben. Ich glaube, weil es eine Studentenstadt ist und die Babbeln, in der wir sind, die alle Social Media unterwegs sind. Man hört die gleiche Musik wie Leute aus Münster, oder was? Genau. Durchschnittlich die Stadt mit dem ähnlichsten Musikgeschmack wäre Münster.
Das heisst, wir sind gerade in der Musikepoche nach der Wiener Klassik, sind wir jetzt gerade in der Münster-Modernen. Münster-Popmusik. Ich hingegen war in New York, New York City. Und das glaube ich wegen dieser Broadway-Sachen, die ich höre. Ah, das kann sein. Weil wir ja auch dieses Jahr da waren, viel da gehört haben. Ich generell, glaube ich, viel mehr englischsprachige Songs höre als der Gründerdeutsche. Und weil du natürlich auch viele Lister Keys New York gehört. Aber auch so, ich glaube, ich höre sehr wenig Deutschrap und so, ist gar nicht meins. Ich höre sehr wenig deutsche Texte, deswegen glaube ich auch schon mal eher weg von Münster. Ja, bei mir auf Platz drei das Digimon-Intro. Lebt deinen Traum. Greif nach der Stelle, du bist bereit. Glaub an dich, bald ist es soweit. Oh Gott, jetzt kann ich die nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Wir werden bei dir sein. Sorry, aber jetzt jede Playlist, die wir zusammenstellen, für irgendeine, wenn wir irgendwie eine Show machen und du hast davor eine starke Meinung zu Playlist oder zum Intro-Song.
Vergiss es, dir wurde jetzt gerade alles entzogen und du weisst es, dass es richtig ist.
Und der Song ist ziemlich kurz, der ist so 1,20.
Deswegen muss ich ihn doppelt so oft gehört haben, damit er überhaupt in Betracht gezogen werden kann.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich viermal so häufig gehört wie an anderen Songs. Das ist ein guter Song. Aber hörst du den, weil du den musikalisch so ansprechend findest? Ich finde den super. Weißt du, warum ich glaube, warum du den hörst? Ich bin kein Digimon-Fan. Nein, ich bin kein Digimon-Fan. Ich bin kein Digimon-Fan ich bin kein Digimon-Fan ich bin kein Digimon-Fan ich bin kein Digimon-Fan ich bin kein Digimon-Fan das sage ich na gleich ich bin kein Digimon-Fan ich bin ein Pokémon-Fan aber ich mag das Intro von Digimon ein bisschen mehr Pokémon war mir immer Pokémon ist mir zu unpolitisch Pokémon ist mir einfach zu unpolitisch die Song? ne das Intro aber generell Pokémon ist mir so unpolitisch. Pokémon ist mir einfach zu unpolitisch. Die Song? Ne, das Intro, aber generell. Pokémon ist mir zu unpolitisch. Du hast gerade gesagt, du magst Digimon nicht. Pikachu. Du hast gerade gesagt, du magst Digimon nicht. Ja, genau. Jetzt sagst du Pokémon, jetzt hängst du aber an, Pokémon-Rants zu machen, weil das nicht zu unpolitisch ist. Ne, deswegen schaue ich keinen Pokémon mehr, weil es mir zu unpolitisch ist. Pikachu lehnt von der ersten Folge ab, im Pokéball zu sein. In keiner einzigen Folge kämpft er dafür, dass andere Pokémon nicht auch im Pokéball sein müssen.
Der hat für sich das Sonderrecht erkämpft, rebelliert gegen das Pokémon-System,
schaut aber dabei zu, wie alle anderen Pokémon ständig in Pokéballen sind und sagt nicht irgendwann mal, hey, wollen wir nicht allgemein nicht mehr in Pokéballen sein?
Kein politischer Funke in dieser Serie. Also findest du das ähnlich neoliberalistisch wie Harry Potter, wo Dobby auch nicht versucht, die anderen Hauselfen zu befreien? Ja. Oder Harry, Ron und Hermine auch nicht dafür tun. Ja, ich bin... Und Hermine versucht es ja und sie machen sich lustig über Hermine. Er kämpft für seine persönliche Freiheit, das ist gut, das unterstütze ich, aber ich finde, da muss danach noch ein kollektiver Gedanke folgen. Aber Pikachu ist ein bisschen so eine sassy Queen, weil er will ja auch nicht sich entwickeln. Ich habe nichts ge... ja, richtig, aber er hat kein Problem damit, dass um ihn rum sich alle Pokémon entwickeln, Smetbo bis zur Unkenntlichkeit sich entwickelt, da ist nichts mehr übrig von Wurmli. Alle entwickeln sich zur Unkenntlichkeit weiter, Ja. Aber wenn da so große Tortocks rumstampfen, wo sind die Schickis, ist ihm scheißegal. Und alle so, ach so, du bist noch Pikachu und Pikachu ist alles scheißegal. So, der sagt, ich entwickle mich nicht, ich gehe nicht in Pokéball. Was er sagt, ist nämlich nicht das, er sagt Pika Pika. Das ist seine politische Botschaft, ja, Pika Pika pika er sagt auch ich finde das ziemlich beschreibend für pokémon dass die immer nur ihren eigenen namen sagen mehr als er sagt nicht mal seinen namen er sagt er sagt ich glaube wenn wir statistiken erheben würden welchen teil seines namens würde der anfang glaube ich sehr weit mehr häufiger genannt werden, Pika Pika, Tchu, manchmal auch. Aber das wäre mal eine geile, ich finde das wäre ein cooles Staffelfinale für Pokémon, wenn der letzten Staffel, letzte Folge so ein Schicki sagen würde, Bisasam, Ende, schwarz, Wamm! Und man denkt, what, what the fuck, jetzt ist die Bewusstseinsstufe, die können jetzt ... Ja, ich finde es gut, wir machen so wie so eine Thriller-Serie, solche Cliffhanger bauen wir aber in diese kindliche Pokémon-Reihen. Zum Beispiel Ende Pilot, Ende unserer Thriller-esken Pilotenserie, äh, des Piloten für unserer Pokémon-Serie wäre am Ende der Folge, Es war die ganze Zeit so ein Pikachu will nicht ein Pokéball sein und so was und kämpft ein bisschen für die Freiheit und so was und dann unsere politische Botschaft, am Ende nimmt Pikachu Pika Pika so einen Pokéball in der Hand, Pika Pika, Pika, Pika, sieht Ash, Pika Pika, guckt auf den Pokéball, Pika Pika, Pika, dann nimmt er den Pokéball und wirft ihn auf Ash und schwarz! Ash wird reingesausogen, ruft doch Blink, blink, blink, blink, bewegt sich, bewegt sich, eingeloggt, schwarz. What? Pikachu und Ash gefangen?
Ja, und danach wird nie wieder darauf eingegangen.
Nie!
Es ist einfach immer so ein Cliffhanger, jedes Mal, jedes Mal.
Genau, dann zweite Folge, Shiggy sagt, Shiggy, Shiggy, Shiggy, wie ist der Samen?
Schwarz, das Kino ist da. What?
What?
Moment mal, Schiggy identifiziert sich als Bisazam oder er kann aus der empathischen Position von anderen sprechen?
Was ist los? Das ganze Kino bleibt noch sitzen und diskutiert.
What?
Was passiert hier?
Ende Folge 3.
Pikachu, Bisazam, Chillin' Bersam.
Das spielt keine Rolle die ganze Zeit, das ist ganz normal Pokémon, aber die Enten sind so krass. Und dann sagt, dann sitzen die zusammen und dann sagt Chicky so, Chicky, Chicky, spielen sie mit so einem Stück Gras. Pika, sagt Pika, Pika, Pika. Und dann gucken sie sich so an und sehen so kleine Würmer rumkriechen. Und dann denken die beiden, haben dann kleine Pokébälle und fangen die kleinen Pokémon. Und dann lassen die die kleinen Pokémon gegeneinander kämpfen. So, schwarz. folge vier ende folge Folge vier, oh nein, oh nein, Glumanda, er ist verletzt, er muss ins Pokercenter, er muss ins Pokercenter. Wir nehmen natürlich Glumanda an, kein Problem. Die Krankenschwester nimmt den verletzten Glumanda, tut ihn in eine Kiste, nimmt aus einer anderen Kiste einen anderen Glumanda raus und gibt ihn zurück. Hier ist ihr Glumander.
So, und dann noch nicht schwarz. Dann, ciao, ciao. Wir bleiben aber bei der Poké-Center-Frau. Und sie fährt diese tote Kiste, fährt den toten Glumander und schmeißt den, und dann geht sie hinten noch so ein Tor auf und schmeißt Glumander runter. und wir sind Kamerafeld auf und wir sind so einen riesen Haufen mit toten Glumanders nur, weil es fucking der eine Raum war, wo die Glumanders sind, und wir fahren auf und wir sehen so Halden und hinten auch noch so grosse Bulldozer, die so tote Schiggis wegräumen, hinten, dann fährt es weiter auf, hinten sehen wir so einen brennenden Haufen Turtox, Qualm, wir fahren auf, Qualm, Brachland und vorne die drei, unsere drei Helden, die so rausgehen.
Zeit für ein neues Abenteuer!
Pika Pika, Pika, Lumanga!
Ja genau, und hinten einfach die grosse Pokémon-Verbrennungsanlage, schwarz, das Pokémon, äh das Kino, what?
Das ist eine Serie, die auch ausschließlich im Kino läuft, das ist einfach jedes Mal, ah. Dann, Folge sechs. Am Ende campen alle, Abenteuer überstanden, Team Rocket wurde mal wieder besiegt, alle liegen im Zelt und so schlafen und ah, wir freuen uns auf die nächste, wir wollen weiter reisen nach Venturia City, wie heissen diese Städte? Aventurien. Falsches Franchise.
Vertania City.
So die Campen und so, ah, morgen geht's weiter, morgen geht's weiter.
Alle schlafen ein, wir sind bei Pikachu nah am Gesicht.
Augen gehen auf.
Pikachu ist wach, er sieht schlafende Menschen neben sich.
Er überlegt, was macht er.
Guckt, geht, hüpft langsam, pika, pika,, was macht er. Hüpft langsam zu Ash, zieht ein Messer aus der Tasche und schneidet ihm die Kehle durch. Schwarz. Rebellion der Pokémon. Er nimmt und klaut die Pokébälle. Schwarz, ja. Stark. Und dann wurde die Serie abgesetzt. Und niemand weiss, was zur Hölle überhaupt los ist. Aber wie hoch muss der Drang sein, wenn du so eine Kinderserie machst, so ein Bullshit einzubauen? Einfach, ich stelle es dir vor, wo du denkst, komm, einmal. Einmal, irgend sowas. Es tut mir jetzt auch leid für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die mit Pokémon nicht so viel anfangen konnten, die letzte halbe Stunde. Aber, oh Gott, ich finde es so perfekt. Es ist so ein bisschen wie Digimon. Es ist so ein bisschen wie Digimon, müsst ihr verstehen. Oh, fände ich das gut. Es ist so wie Digimon, nur mit einem schlechteren Infosong. Und weniger politisch. Das stimmt, ja. Digimon ist extrem politisch. Weiß ich nicht. Nie gesehen. Habe ich auch nicht wirklich viel gesehen. Ich weiss noch, wie wir damals gemeinsam die erste Folge Digimon geschaut haben, der ganze Freundeskreis. Lebe deinen Traum, denn es wird wahr. Denn es wird wahr. Denn er wird wahr. Geh deinen Weg, stell dich dir Gefahr. Alles, was wichtig ist, wirst du erkennen, wenn die Zeit gekommen ist. Lebe deinen Traum, denn er wird wahr. Schwieriger, nicht so schöner Satz. Auch nicht, ne? Lebe deinen Traum, denn er wird wahr. Lebe deinen Traum, dann ist er wahr. Ja, und vor allem, wenn er wahr wird, dann kannst du nicht anders, als ihn zu leben. Also was sollst leben also was soll sie denn sonst machen okay ändere nichts denn alles passiert wie ich gerade gesagt habe geh deinen weg stelle dich der gefahr lebt deinen traum denn er wird wahr geh deinen weg auch gewisserweise macht nicht weiter sondern es ist immer noch der gleiche satz wie lebt deinen traum geh deinen, denn stelle dich der Gefahr, alles was wichtig ist, wirst du erkennen, wenn die Zeit gekommen ist.
Greif nach den Sternen, du bist bereit, glaub an dich, bald ist es soweit.
Okay, das ist der Text, für den du dich entschieden hast, den willst du so oft hören, dass er in meiner Spotify-Rap-Playlist ganz oben steht.
Das ist dieser frühkindliche Text. Wir bleiben Freunde, was auch immer passiert. Das heißt, dein Topkünstler ist Mozart und dein Topsong ist das Digimon-Intro. Mozart dreht sich im Grabe um, wie so ein Dönerspies. Ja, aber er macht so ein Salto. Was für ein Salto der macht, ey.
Er so, ich habe doch nicht so viel Kram geschrieben dafür, dass ich mit dem Digimon-Intro bei Spotify verrappt bin. Tatsächlich ein ähnliches Phänomen, wie du gerade aus der Sicht von Mozart beschreibst, hatten wir ja auch, weil viele von euch haben uns natürlich auch dankenswerterweise eingeschickt, dass das Podcast-Ufo bei euch am Podcast-Recap des Jahres war. Aber interessant ist auch immer, Leute geschickt haben, die so, ah, Podcast Sufe auf zwei.
Und man denkt sich so, wer ist auf eins? Warum ist Joe Rogan auf Platz eins? Und es ist genauso wie Mozart, der auf Platz eins ist, aber unter ihm ist Digimon. Manchmal kann selbst der erste Platz bei Unpassendem zweiten Platz nicht so viel wert sein. Ja, völlig richtig. Selbst bei Olympia, wenn du sehr, sehr gut bist, machst du den ersten Preis, den ersten Platz. Und auf Platz zwei ist ein Staubsauger aus Finnland. Oder ein Kind. Dann denkt man, vielleicht habe ich einfach die falsche Sportart gewählt. Also man denkt sich, es ist abwertend auf eine Art. Klar, zu Hause das Kind und der Staubsauger längst vergessen und du hast dann noch diese Goldmedaille bei dir am Kühlschrank hängen. Cool. Immer im Hinterkopf hast du das war zu einfach. Wir lieben natürlich alle Podcasts, ist klar. Aber wir hassen auch die vielen. Wir hassen auch, also naja, wir lieben aber auch viele. Ja, ja, nee, wir lieben eine Menge und vielen Dank für alle, die uns da geschrieben haben. Süß immer die Leute, die gesagt, die irgendwie so zehntausend Minuten haben, was ich auch noch viel finde, ehrlich gesagt. Oh ja. Und dann geschrieben haben, ha, habe ich wohl am meisten gehört. Nein, es gibt immer, there is always a bigger fish, es gibt immer Leute. Es gibt immer jemanden, der mehr eingeschlafen ist zu Podcast-Folgen als du. Mach dir keine Illusion. Mach dir keine Gedanken, glaub, geh deinen Weg, stell dich der Gefahr. Denn er wird wahr, denn sie wird fucking wahr, die Gefahr wird wahr. Gefahr auf Wahrheim finde ich wiederum gut. Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, ob man nicht so eine Olympiade der Staubsauger machen könnte. Da hast du mich jetzt ein bisschen gekitzelt gerade, weil die Olympiade für mich hat sich auserzählt. Gegenstand, wir machen Stiftung Warentest, die Olympiade. Ja, genau. Eigentlich so eine Stiftung Warentest Sendung wäre ohnehin geil und du sagst, zum Beispiel Staubsauger, du hast fünf Staubsauger und die hängst du so an die Wand. Wer kann durch Saugkraft sein eigenes Gewicht halten? Eigentlich wie die Murmel Olympiade, nur halt fucking sinnvoll als Verbrauchertest. Ja, genau. Und du brauchst ein richtig aufgepeitschtes Publikum, die richtig Bock haben.
Fünf Staubsauger treten gegeneinander an, die besten oder teuersten oder so ein Shit. Hängen die an die Decke, so dass die sich festsaugen und guck, wer kann am längsten hängen. Ist das die erste Disziplin? Das ist das eins. So, zweite Disziplin ist maximal viel Dreck wegmachen. Ja, wie viel kann eingesaugt werden. Riesen-A Riesen-Aquarium mit Staub. Oder Aquarienweise Staub. Und dann reinstecken. Musste man da irgendwie Requisiten neu verwenden von der vorherigen Sendung, wo für Budget- Sendungen ganz viel gekauft wurde, was am Ende gar nicht mehr in der Sendung rankam? Naja, wir haben Aquarien gekauft, am Ende war es Aquarientest. Und dann ganz viel Staub raus und welcher am längsten durchhält, also das grösste Fassungsvermögen hat gewinnt.
Ja, okay, das ist natürlich cool, was ich natürlich als kompetitiver Mensch gerne sehen würde, wäre irgendeine Art von Eins gegen Eins.
Also die Staubsauger treten direkt gegeneinander an. Also wirklich mal zu sagen, du hast in der Mitte so einen Tennisball liegen und die Staubsauger sind beide auf einen Meter Abstand,
werden gleichzeitig angemacht und wer zieht den Tennisball zu sich, wer hat mehr Saugkraft, einfach direkt eins gegen eins, kannst du sogar vier, du kannst vier gleichzeitig in so einem Quadratanordnung, eins gegen eins gegen eins, genau, kannst du machen und dann in welche Richtung geht es, ah Schweden gewinnt, Schweden gewinnt den Saugball, ah das Land, der ist Herstellers, jedes Land schickt ein Gerät ins Rennen. Wo wir die jute alte Bosch. Die jute alte Bosch. So, und dann natürlich auch die Olympiade der Toaster, wo du halt auch wirklich so einen richtig harten tost. Der Toast ist eiskalt. Der Toast kommt direkt aus der Gefriertruhe. Wer schafft es noch, den zu tosten am schnellsten? Du musst halt eine gute Mischung finden aus eins gegen eins und so viele treten an, wie ein Marathonfeld. Ja, genau. Finde ich auch gut. Aber ich finde, du brauchst beides. Du brauchst beides. Wir können auch Teams machen. Wir können auch Teams, zwei gegen zwei, doppel. Können wir auch machen, auf jeder Seite zwei Toaster, irgendwie so Hochsprung oder so. Oder halt so wie Staffel, der Toast fliegt vom einen Toaster in den nächsten, dass man sozusagen zu zweit erstmal irgendwie auf Stufe drei beim einen, auf Stufe drei beim anderen und der Gesamttostungsvorgang zählt sowas in der richtung finde ich natürlich noch preis irgendwie ich finde wenn er billig ist wo jemand den preis sagt ja wo jemand einfach vor ganz vor weiss hinten ganz trocken den preis sagt der toaster kostet 39 euro 13,99 der toaster aus Dänemark kostet vier99 Euro. Der Toaster aus Dänemark kostet 40 Euro. Einer im Publikum klatscht. Aber na gut, ich finde nämlich schon, dass angenommen ein sehr billiger Toaster landet auf Platz zwei. Und so ein super teurer landet auf Platz drei oder sowas. Finde ich schon, dass der ein Upgrade verdient hat. Jetzt machst du es kompliziert. Ich weiß, ich will es ja auch nicht. Will ich das? Nein. Platz zwei. Aber warum machst du es dann? Ja, ich denke nur, es ist auch wichtig, dass er den Preis in einem zieht. Ja, es stimmt schon, es ist schon ein Punkt. Vielleicht, oh, wir machen es folgendermaßen. Jedes Land hat ein Budget. Jedes Land kriegt 1000 Euro und kann selber entscheiden, welche Geräte es ins Rennen schickt. Und dann muss man halt so
das Olympische Komitee überlegen, okay,
wir nehmen die richtig teure Waschmaschine,
dafür den Billo-Toaster,
dafür haben wir mehr Budget für den
Staubsauger.
Und dann haben wir irgendwie noch die Toilette,
da können wir noch mal ein bisschen
mehr Geld reintun. Und dann hat jedes Land ein Budget
und kann es ins Rennen schicken. Und dann wird halt interdisziplinär geguckt, wer hat am Ende die meisten Goldmedaillen für ein Gesamtbudget. Das ist doch eine geile Idee. Super. Das ist eine gute Idee. Man mochte Geräte gar nicht, man könnte einfach nacheinander Geld setzen und wer die meisten Runden gewinnt hat, gewonnen. Weißt du, was ich meine? Meinst du Casino-Olympiade, oder? Ne, man könnte sich einen Schnickschnack sparen und einfach, du bist Finnland, ich bin Serbien, wir sind im Finale, wir haben alle 1000 Euro in der Tasche, so und jetzt ist Runde eins, ich lege 1000, du legst zwei, nee, wir haben alle 1000 Euro in der Tasche, ich lege 10 Euro, du legst 20 Euro, der erste Punkt geht an dich. Ich kriege deine 10 Euro? Nee. Ach so. Wir setzen halt von diesem...
Das ist halt eigentlich genau das Gleiche, was du gerade
vorgeschlagen hast. Okay. Wer mehr
setzt, hat gewonnen. Genau.
Und das halt bis fünf Punkte.
Das hast du schon eins null. Also ich nehme jetzt wahrscheinlich
irgendwie so hundert. Aber du clever bist, nimmst du
zweihundert und gewinnst wieder als Punkt zwei.
Ich hab schon sehr viel Geld verloren, aber
jetzt setze ich sechs... Lass uns das mal
spielen. Was? Ich bin Finnland, du bist Serbien. Jeder hat tausend. Okay. Okay, pass auf, tausend. Das ist ein albernes Spiel. Okay. Okay, Problem ist jetzt. Also die erste Runde, jeder muss aufschreiben, was er setzt. Okay. Komm schon, ich bin Serien. Mein Heimatland, meine ganze Familie, schaut zu. Okay, ich habe es aufgeschrieben, was ich ... Okay, also, als erste Runde, ich setze ein Euro. Ich auch. Ich habe ein Euro gewonnen. Aber okay, das heißt, wer gewinnt jetzt? Ja, unentschieden. Unentschieden, okay, wir haben beide noch 99 Euro. 999 Euro. Okay, gut, alles klar. Okay. Okay. Alles klar? Ja. Ich setze drei Euro. Ich setze auch drei Euro! Ich setze auch drei!
Ich dachte auch, du machst zwei.
Okay, unentschieden, unentschieden.
Das Lustige ist, wir sind genau gleich clever. Wir denken beide genau gleich weit.
Vor allem dieses Spiel geht jetzt noch unendlich lange weiter, weil wir immer exakt das Gleiche machen.
Das ist ja sehr lustig jetzt, weil ich dachte, das ist ja clever, weil der Weg zum Ziel ist natürlich, haben wir beide erkannt, relativ schnell, jetzt gerade, Props an uns, dass man Punkte holt, indem man sehr, sehr billig verliert. Ja, billig verlieren, teuer gewinnen. Oder billig gewinnt. Ja. Genau, oder den anderen ausnimmt. Ja, ja. Genau, aber du musst möglichst, wenn du verlierst, sehr wenig wenig jetzt um mehr zu haben und den anderen auszunehmen so lassen wir mal weitermachen
wie viel gilt haben wir noch 996 noch nicht so viel gesetzt okay Alles klar, die dritte Schätzung ist 101 Euro.
Ich setze 80.
Stark.
Habe ich ganz gut gewonnen.
101, fuck.
Okay, das ist ein Punkt für dich.
Jetzt kannst du mir abziehen, 101 Euro von 196.
Das musst du dir selber aufschreiben.
Okay, es geht bis drei.
Was ist 996 minus 101?
101.
Also habe ich noch.
101 ist nicht dumm, ey, Stefan.
Okay, du hast 895 habe ich noch und du hast?
Ich habe 916.
Okay, und ich führe, ne?
1-0 jetzt.
Okay, gut.
1-0 für Schweden. Okay, ich setze. Ich setze 1. 1 Euro. Nein, nicht dein Ernst. Okay, wir haben wieder ein Unterschied.
Oh Mann, hätte ich zwei gesagt, wie gut das wäre.
Oh fuck, ich bin so dumm. Wir beide sind geizig, wir sind richtig geizig einfach.
Wir wollen nichts.
Das ist bei Geld, was wir nicht besitzen. Ja, geben wir nichts aus.
Okay.
Gut. Okay. Gut. Okay. Also, Unentschieden ist eins zu null für Stefan. Der nächste Einsatz sind vier Euro. Ich setze fünf Euro! Yes! Ich habe genau antizipiert, dass du drei denkst, vier und fünf. Okay, eins, eins, alles klar.
Wie viel hast du noch?
Ich habe noch neunhundertzehn.
Wacht, ich habe acht und neunzig, eins zu eins.
Okay.
Alles klar. Wir spielen bis drei, ne?
Ja. Gut. Okay. Ich setze 101 Euro. Ich setze 351. Okay. Ganz kurz für den Deutschen Podcastpreis, Zentrale at Podcast minus UFO. Genau, Beschwerden einfach an Zentrale, die gehen wir beide extrem an.
Jederzeit erreichen.
Okay. Zwei Eins für dich. Zwei1. Und du könntest jetzt gewinnen. Das ist jetzt super uncool. Es hat natürlich einen Vorteil. Naja, es gibt, du gewinnst auf jeden Fall. Nee, ich habe doch jetzt gerade 300 gesetzt und du 100. Du hast doch mehr als ich jetzt noch wie viel hast du denn noch das muss ich das immer sagen ich habe fünfhundert
neunundvierzig fünfhundert neunundvierzig und ich habe siebenhundertneunundachtzig okay fünfhundertneunundvierzig hast du mhm okay dein einsatz ja mal. Sag es, du kannst es jetzt nicht ändern. Du kannst dich alle still nicht ändern. Kurz mein Gedankenprozess, damit es auch ein bisschen interessant wird für Leute, die zuhören, ist, am liebsten würde ich dich jetzt ja ausnehmen. Aber dann gewinnst du. Also kann ich dich nicht ausnehmen, also muss ich auf die Nummer sicher gehen. Also setze ich 550 Euro. Ich habe zwei. Zwei gesetzt. Genau, das war mir klar. Das war mir klar. Das heißt, okay, jetzt steht es zwei zu zwei. Wie viel hast du noch? Ich habe noch 547. I hate this game! Folgt mir da irgendeine Logik? Ich weiß, woran das mich erinnert? Auch an Skat.
Ja, okay.
Du trumpfst die ganze Zeit, da bin ich auch schon schlecht drin.
Okay, also.
Nächste Runde.
Was setzt du?
Ja, du gewinnst ja.
Du musst sagen, was du setzt.
Wieso?
Tu es.
Du hast gewonnen.
Sag, was du setzt.
Ich setze.
Zwei.
547. Ja, natürlich. Alles klar, damit gewinnt Serbien. Du hast gesagt, wir machen das anstatt den ganzen Küchengeräten, wolltest du abkürzen. Also Serbien gewinnt jetzt die Küchengerät-Olympiade, abgekürzt durch dieses Geldsetzspiel. Superspannendes Spiel, aber. Ah, sehr schön. Ich kenne das mit Fleischwürsten. Wie wir drei Unentschieden haben.
Ich kenne das mit Fleischwürsten.
Jeder hat eine Fleischwurst und scheit ein Schneiden ab, oder was?
Genau. Und du musst mal nur ein Wiegen.
Finde ich auch eine gute Idee.
Das Fleischwurstspiel.
Allein da haben wir noch wieder eine komplette Sendung, oder?
Du meinst die hier?
Ja.
Unter uns nein, ich würde das jetzt nicht nochmal.
Wir machen nächste Folge, bringt ihr eine Fleischwurst, eine Gurke und eine Karotte mit und ein Kilo Reis und dann machen wir das den ganzen Abend. Machen wir den ganzen Abend. Ganzen fucking Abend. Och Gott, ey, okay, spannend, spannend, spannend, aber am Ende ist halt einfach keine Chance mehr, wenn du halt, es ist wie beim Poker, aber dann hast du irgendwann keinen Chipberg mehr vor dir durch zwei Glückentschescheidungen und schon, ja, ich will jetzt nicht mehr rausreden, du hast fair gewonnen und das gut gemacht. Mit drei Unentschieden finde ich, aber hat man gesehen, wir waren sehr nah aneinander, wir haben oft gleich gedacht, weil wir einfach beide viel Zeit miteinander verbringen. Muss man sagen, wir sind ein bisschen im Kopf, ich bin so häufig in deinem Kopf und manchmal gefällt mir nicht, was ich da sehe, Ja? Unaufgeräumt. Das Spiel den ganzen Tag das Digimon-Intro. Das ganze Zeit blärrt aus allen Boxen. Das Digimon-Intro. Und du hast noch so alte Boxen. So verzerrt das Digimon-Intro. So alte Laptop-Boxen. Und sehr viele History-Facts. Ja, ja. Ja, ich muss daran denken, an meinen Mitbewohner. Hust lieber ab. Nicht, dass da noch gleich was in der Stimme landet. Okay, ich muss immer daran denken, an meinen Mitbewohner. Der ist ein großer Fan von klassischer Musik auch. Auch wie ich, wie die man bewiesen hat. Und der hat immer Musik gehört auf seinem Laptop. Ziemlich schlechter Laptop damals,, so 2011er MacBook. Und dann habe ich gesagt, hey, wenn du so ein großer Fan von klassischer Musik bist, warum kaufst du dir nicht mal irgendwie eine coole Soundanlage und hörst es immer nur auf deinem alten Laptop? Und dann meinte er, nee, die Musik ist so gut, die kann man auch auf einem schlechten Lautsprecher hören. Und ich dachte mir, ergibt das Sinn oder ergibt das gerade keinen Sinn? Und bis heute weiss ich's nicht. Also, ergibt es Sinn, dass du einen guten Film kannst du auch im Flugzeug schauen, weil der ist so gut, du brauchst keinen Effekt, Spektakel, du brauchst keinen Tonwert. Selbst ein schlechtes Rezeptionserlebnis ist immer noch besser als, ich weiß nicht, schlechte Filme zu gucken im Kino. Genau, lieber einen guten Film im Flugzeug als einen schlechten Film im IMAX. Boah, das Ding ist ja, warum beschneidest du dich? Das ist ja die Frage. Warum verkürzt du dich selber? Du kannst ja beides haben. Deswegen ergibt es keinen Sinn. Finnland ergibt keinen Sinn, weil er hat damit ja nicht auf die Frage geantwortet, ob er sich nicht einfach eine Anlage leisten könnte. ja vielleicht kann er sich einfach einer kaufen und dann könnte er die klassische musik genauso hören und es wäre noch geiler ich sage jetzt jetzt, ich habe mir seine Box ausgeliehen und die ist mir dann leider, also da ist mir leider eine Fanta reingeflossen. Dann war die leider kaputt, dann habe ich sie ihm zurückgegeben. Also, er konnte sich halt keine neue kaufen. Rückblickend, wäre sie mit einer Cola auch kaputt gegangen? Gute Frage. Du hast auch die Olympiade der Softdrinks.
Wer kann mehr kaputt machen, wer kann eine Pflanze kaputt machen?
Das ist gut.
Aber findest du, also jetzt mal eine Moralfrage, wenn du was ausleihst und du machst es kaputt, sollte man das erwähnen, wenn man es zurückgibt?
Nee, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, ja doch.
Ja, wirklich?
Da muss ich ja sehr uncool sein.
Ja, gibt es bitte, was ich schon mal, ich habe schon mal was verloren, was ich mir ausgeliehen habe, hab's dann neu gekauft und zurückgegeben. Und das nicht gesagt? Nee. Okay, das Tetris-Spiel meines Cousins, jetzt kann ich's ja sagen. Er hat mit Tetris damals geliehen für den Gameboy, ich hab das sehr gerne gespielt, verloren. Wie verliert man denn Tetris-Spiel? Fliegt einfach aus dem Gameboy raus, einfach mitten im Spiel. Ich bin verzweifelt. Es war weg, ich bin verzweifelt. Mein Cousin wollte es wieder haben und ich habe es dann einfach neu kaufen müssen mit meinem Taschengeld und ihm dann gegeben. Würdest du sagen, es gibt einen Punkt, ab dem man Geliehenes nicht mehr zurückfordern darf? Ja. Also würdest du sagen, ich leihe dir Fight Club, die DVD, und dann vier Jahre später sage ich, hey, kannst du mir die Fight Club DVD zurückgeben? Gibt es nicht einen Punkt, wo man einfach sagt, nein, du hast den Anspruch einfach verloren? Nee, ich finde nicht vier Jahre, ich finde, es geht eher darum, wie viel Relevanz hat das Medium noch. Weil jetzt zum Beispiel, ich räume ja gerade... Also da würdest du den Aktualitätskoeffizienten des Mediums noch mit einbauen. Exakt, weil angenommen, weiss ich nicht, DVD im Blu-ray gab es ja ein ganz klares Datum, wo es dann Blu-rays gab. Ja. Und du sagst danach, ein Jahr später, nachdem es schon lange Blu-Rays gibt, kann ich deine DVD von Dings weg haben? Nee, das hast du verspielt.
Also du würdest es gar nicht tatsächlich am Zeitraum festmachen, sondern an der Fortschritt der Technik? Der Zeitraum spielt eine Rolle, aber bitte berechnen wir den Koeffizienten des Aktualitäts-Mediums noch mit ein.
Ich würde behaupten, ich habe jetzt nämlich seit irgendwie zehn Jahren CDs von der Dave-Matthews-Band von einem Kumpel aus der Schule, ein Schulkumpel, die geliehen. Jetzt räume ich ja gerade mein Kinderzimmer auf, weil das Haus ja bald weg ist. Und jetzt diese CDs, viele davon schmeiße ich weg oder verschenke die, weil CDs habe ich jetzt auch keine Verwendung mehr für, weil man kann einfach alles streamen, das ist alles egal, für ihn aber auch, denke ich mir, er hat ja auch keinen Bock mehr zurückzubekommen, weil er kann Dave Matthews Band ja gut und gerne bei Spotify hören. Ja, ja, ja, ja, das stimmt, also an irgendeinem Punkt ist es dann wieder unhöflich, das zurückzugeben, dieses klassische Ausräumen und dann hier ist deine Kiste von Sachen, die du mir alle geliehen hast und so. Ja, gut, wir hoffen, dass dir wunderbar ins neue Jahr kommt. Es wird ein tolles Jahr. Es wird ganz, ganz fantastisch. Wollen wir ein paar Prophezeiungen machen? Ich werde 30. Oh, okay. 2024 ist das Jahr, an dem Stefan aufhört, 19 zu sein. Ja. Und du machst ja den relativ gewagten Sprung von 19 auf 30.
Genau, richtig.
Du gehst ja von 19 direkt auf 30.
Ja.
Was hat das für einen Hintergrund? Wie hast du dich dazu entschieden?
Ich bin jung gehalten und dann plötzlich werden die Jahre immer schneller vorbei.
Du hast ja so einen Kredit aufgenommen, einen Zeitkredit. Du wolltest, du hast dich ja mit 19 einfrieren lassen quasi.
Genau.
Und dann habe ich halt immer das...
Du hast dich elf Jahre lang auftauen lassen.
Genau. Und oben waren, muss man sich vorstellen, so Infusionen habe ich bekommen von so Kleinkindern, die wurden so auf so … Das Rückenmark von Kleinkindern. Genau, auf so ein Metallding gespiess, und dann wird das Rückenmark, die Leben, die müssen am Leben erhalten, das ist nicht so, soll man eigentlich nicht. Also sage ich kurz, man soll das eigentlich nicht mehr machen. Soll man ja nicht mehr machen. Aber ich sage mal, ich kann es mir leisten. Und ich meine, das ist schon gut, das ist richtig geil. Und dann wird mir das ein reingespritzt in meine Venen. Deswegen bin ich nach wie vor 19, kann es mir aber jetzt nicht mehr leisten. Und deswegen bin ich nächstes Jahr schlagartig 30. Das heisst, wenn du auch mit dieser Behandlung aufhörst, dann geht der gesamte Fortschritt schlagartig verloren. Ja. In dem Moment, in dem du aufhörst. Diese Hating-Tour aus Hollywood, die alle Hollywoodstars nehmen, damit sie keinen Haarausfall bekommen, ist ja auch so. Wenn man damit aufhört, wählt man sofort alle Haare. Das ist so lustig. Das heißt, wenn du eine Woche vergisst, diese Hating-Tour zu benutzen. Exakt, und dann Tom Cruise plötzlich alles weg. Ja, es gibt diese Hating-Tour, die nehmen die alle, seitdem die 18, 19, 20 sind. Und wenn man die immer nimmt, ist es super teuer, aber die haben ja auch das Geld häufig. Und wenn man die immer nimmt, kein Problem, dann ist es wirklich nachweislich, hast du dann keine Herrlein, die zurückgeht und kriegst keine Pläte. Wenn du aber aufhörst, das zu nehmen, was entweder der genialste Werbeclame aller Zeiten ist,
oder stimmt glücklicherweise für Unternehmen, das wäre so lustig, wenn die sagen,
ihre Testergebnisse von ihren Produkten zurück, eine gute oder eine schlechte Nachricht.
Die gute Nachricht ist, es wirkt.
Wenn man es nimmt, kriegt man keinen Ausfall.
Schlechte Nachricht ist, wenn man aufhört damit, also aufhört, ihnen Geld zu geben für das Produkt, dann verliert man sofort alle Haare. Ah. Oh nein. Ja, das, ach nee, dann müssen die uns immer mehr Geld geben, ja, unter Tisch high fight. Aber sie können es ganz einfach korrigieren, indem sie diese eine, dann müssen sie nur einmal nehmen. Ja, müssen wir gucken, müssen wir gucken. Genau, also wenn sie einfach ein bisschen Fanta, lustigerweise. Vielen, vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung. Wir haben gemessen, nee, nur kurz kurz. Wir gucken, was wir unseren Chemiker noch mal an. Wir müssen leider los, das Taxi hupt. Wenn man ein bisschen Fanta reinmacht. Hören Sie es hupen? Ich höre es hupen. Ich höre es nicht hupen. Ich höre es hupen. Es ist kein Taxi. Es steht leider mitten im Halteverbot. Ich sehe die Glaswände. Wir haben Glaswände. Sie sind ein bisschen weiter weg von der Strasse. Wenn man ein bisschen Fanta reinmacht, muss man es nur einmal nehmen. Ich höre es hupen, Sie hören es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mehr hupen. Deswegen, wir müssen los, tut mir leid, schicken uns eine Mail, schicken uns eine Mail, danke schön, tschüss, da wird Geldscheine in die Luft geworfen, wuhuuhu. Oder auch wie so ein Abnehmmittel, das du immer nehmen musst, und wenn du es nicht nimmst, nimmst du schlagartig 30 Kilo zu, einfach bap, mach alles, was du dir Zeit gespart hast, kommt dann wieder zurück. Finde ich genial. Das ist gemein. Oh, was ich gut finde, wir machen eine App, wenn du regelmäßig Sport machst. Wie könnten wir die nennen? Das Podcast-Ufo. Okay. Und dann machen wir regelmäßig Sport und wenn man aufhört, Sport zu machen, kriegst du eine Wagenladung Snickers und so süssige Süssigkeiten so umsonst. Okay.
So als Bestrafung. Damit du dich wieder fett wirst. Dann wird halt fett wieder. Und was genau haben wir davon, dass wir denen kostenlose Snacks geben? Ne, das ist genau das gleiche. Wir geben denen so eine, die Steaks sind höher, weil die sofort wieder fett werden, wenn sie aufhören, unsere App zu benutzen. Und die bezahlen dann mehr für die App, weil sie wissen, die haben ein gutes Bestrafungssystem, dass wenn ich aufhöre, kriege ich ganz viel Snickers. Sache umsonst. Okay. Genial. Und mehr von diesen Ideen werdet ihr in diesem Jahr bekommen. Haltet mal die Augen offen beim App Store. Haltet mal die Augen offen. Haltet mal eure Augen. Haltet mal die Augen. So Clockwork Orange mässig. Haltet die offen. Also schneidet euch so, schneidet euch diese Augenklammern hin und dann stellt das Handy in den Stativ und dann, dass ihr schön darauf achtet, falls was kommt.
Es kann gut sein, dass 2024 die erste das Podcast UFO App kommt.
Ich möchte ja nicht zu viel verraten, vielleicht kommt da was, aber ansonsten wünschen wir euch einen schönen neuen Jahresanfang und versprechen euch, es geht weiter.
Genau so ist es.
Glaubt uns, bitte, bitte, glaubt uns, es werden weitere Folgen kommen.
Bitte, bitte, bitte, glaubt uns.
Bitte denkt nicht, dass wir lügen.
Das grösste Problem, was wir haben, ist Glaubwürdigkeit.
Bitte, bitte, denkt nicht, dass wir euch anlügen.
Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte.
Wir heben ab.
Wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Wollen wir das dieses Jahr lassen?
Ah, komm.
It's a world world.